some shows go past their prime some
never find their footing and some just
don't do what executives want them to do
from bull to batwoman to babysitters
club a lot of tv shows have already been
canceled in 2022 and we're here to let
you know the reasons why they got the
axe
fitting right in on cbs schedule full of
crime and legal procedurals bull is
about the previously little-known world
of jury consulting inspired by the
former career of talk show host and
executive producer dr phil mcgraw it ran
for six seasons on cbs spending its
first two years among the top 10 most
watched programs on broadcast tv but
then on january 18th 2022 lead actor
michael weatherly tweeted that he was
ready to leave bull and cbs then opted
to cancel the show rather than continue
on without its anchor and besides after
six seasons the show was no longer the
ratings juggernaut it once was ranking
as the eighth most watched cbs drama
among all viewers and dead last in the
sought after 18 to 49 demographic but i
feel confident we can turn that around
in another generation or two
in january 2022 abc launched promised
land a throwback to the primetime soap
operas of the 70s and 80s it was set at
a picturesque california winery
detailing the machinations and romantic
entanglements of several generations of
a sprawling spoiled family alas promised
land brought in the lowest 18 to 49
numbers of any abc drama in the 2021-22
season and it lasted just five episodes
on the prime time schedule subsequent
installments were then dropped directly
on hulu while creator mac lopez claimed
on instagram that the move didn't equal
a cancellation the low ratings and
unceremonious dumping make a second
season highly unlikely
robert langdon is a world-renowned
symbolist the go-to expert for finding
clues in ancient works of art and
historical artifacts to uncover
far-reaching conspiracies he's the hero
of multiple best-selling novels by dan
brown as well as the lost symbol a 2020
peacock original starring ashley
zuckerman as langdon brown's novels were
all massive best sellers and three big
screen adaptations starring tom hanks
earned a worldwide box office of more
than 1.4 billion dollars but each film
made less than the previous and the last
one hit theaters more than five years
before the lost symbol debuted so
perhaps robert langdon's time has simply
passed in january 2022 peacock canceled
the show with a source telling variety
that the streamer and producers figured
they'd told a full story in one season
netflix's hentaipide is set in east los
angeles as it explores the experiences
of latinos trying to make their way in a
gentrifying neighborhood it centers on
the morales family as they keep their
grandfather's restaurant open pursue
their own dreams and fight against the
twin menaces of immigration officials
and gentrification despite early signs
of success including strong critical
notices hentafi traded in quality over
quantity and never attracted a sizable
audience or at least not one large
enough for netflix to justify a third
season the streamer doesn't release
specific viewership numbers for any of
its shows but according to deadline the
second and ultimately final season of
hintified never made an appearance on
the netflix top 10.
ann m martin's beloved babysitter's club
books are cultural touchstones for many
readers who grew up in the 80s and 90s
and lapped up the heartwarming stories
of tween girl small business owners in
suburban connecticut the books have been
adapted before but netflix's version
that debuted in 2020 earned an outsized
amount of praise despite this critical
success the babysitter's club was
cancelled in march 2022 after two
seasons in an interview with vulture
creator rachel shukert revealed that
even though the series pulled in solid
viewership numbers it may not have been
watched in the manner most preferable to
netflix shugert hypothesized that the
streamer wants to devote more resources
to widely appealing shows that are
immediately binge watched upon release
and draw in new markets rather than
quieter shows with a more niche audience
but still
everyone got a little of what they
needed that day
netflix was highly motivated to land
space force which premiered in may 2020
it marked the return to series tv for
steve carell and his reunion with the
office showrunner greg daniels in a
satire of government life during the
donald trump administration carell
played an air force general picked to
head up the fledgling new branch of the
military known as space force the second
season dropped in february 2022 with a
new co-showrunner and production
transferred from los angeles to
vancouver these changes were undertaken
to improve the show's critical quality
and buzz as well as to cut costs the
first season was among the most
expensive shows on contemporary tv but
the viewership figures didn't justify
such an expense especially after april
2022 when netflix reported a massive
subscriber loss and endured a 55 billion
dollar decline in value within a week of
that financial disaster space force was
permanently grounded
batwoman was part of the cw's ambitious
and expansive arrowverse of
interconnected superhero shows initially
starring ruby rose as hero kate kane and
then javicia leslie as criminal turned
caped crusader ryan wilder showrunner
carolyn dries broke the news on twitter
in april 2022 that the show would not be
returning for a fourth season as
reported by variety the cw might be
cleaning house of its underperforming
scripted series as it prepares for an
ownership change it's currently owned by
warner media and viacom cbs with nexstar
media group preparing to buy a majority
stake batwoman was among the least
watched shows on the network in the
2021-2022 season averaging around 760
000 viewers a drop of 20 from the
previous frame
dc's legends of tomorrow follows a
rotating crew of young superheroes
villains and rogues who move through
space time and the universe to prevent
apocalypses and other threats to
humanity it was part of the cw's
arrowverse which dominated the network
in the 2010s but has since been
shrinking in the upcoming 2022 to 2023
season the only shows remaining in the
franchise will be the relatively young
superman and lois and the flash in its
ninth and likely final season legends of
tomorrow was among the oldest and least
popular arrowverse shows concluding
after seven seasons and attracting fewer
viewers than the superhero shows that
survived it reportedly pulled in an
average of just 860 000 watchers in what
wound up being its final season less
than a month after the axe fell the cw
continued to clear out its schedule and
production slate when it canceled seven
more hour-long dramas including dynasty
charmed 4400 roswell new mexico in the
dark legacies and naomi those suckers
are gonna pay for this
countless millennials look back fondly
on the elaborately produced kids game
show legends of the hidden temple like a
mini indiana jones style adventure in a
competitive format the 90s series pitted
six duos against each other as they
raided a supposedly ancient temple
lorded over by a talking stone head
named olmec in search of a priceless
artifact like many fondly remembered 90s
shows legends of the hidden temple
earned a reboot when it arrived on the
cw in october 2021 this revamped bigger
budget version boasts an elaborate set
and features grown-up contestants
instead of kids comedian cristela alonso
hosts while d bradley baker reprises the
role of olmec who remains as eerily
impressive as ever sadly the revamped
legends was met with historically bad
ratings as it reportedly averaged fewer
than 300 000 viewers unsurprisingly then
it was cancelled in june 2022 perhaps
the nostalgia craze that's been gripping
tv lightly is finally over or maybe the
new legends of the hidden temple simply
failed to recapture the original's music
the
2021-2022 season marks the 14th street
year that cbs has been able to call
itself the most watched tv network in
the united states thus compared to other
networks it has higher and more narrow
standards of what constitutes a hit and
which shows are worthy of renewal that
was especially apparent in may 2022 when
cbs canceled one long-running drama and
three sitcoms with middling to low
viewership figures such a culling makes
way for a slew of new series more in
line with the network's hit crime dramas
the axed shows were b-positive united
states of al and how we roll as well as
the magnum pi remake which was later
picked up by nbc at the same time cbs
ordered three new dramas cop show east
new york legal series so help me todd
and firefighter yarn fire country so
help me todd at least sounds like it'll
be good for a laugh every now and then
but you couldn't really call it a comedy
and that's just fine with cbs maybe i
should just let you be
who you want to be
one of the most visually striking sci-fi
shows in recent memory raised by wolves
revolves around two androids mother and
father who are programmed to raise six
human children on a dangerous alien
planet they create a solid space colony
but all their hard work is threatened
when a theological conflict erupts tnt
ordered raised by wolves back in 2018
but it would ultimately premiere on hbo
max in 2020 both seasons of the show
earned strong reviews but the series
couldn't overcome its behind-the-scenes
shuffling in april 2022 warner media and
discovery inc merged to form a new media
company warner brothers discovery
according to raised by wolves star abu
bakr salim this merger brought an early
end to many productions including the
sleek sci-fi show he expressed hope
however that it might be picked up and
continue on another platform if enough
fans push for a rescue
following nancy drew and the hardy boyz
the cw's tom swift was the latest gritty
contemporary reimagining of a
decades-old young adult novel series
loosely based on the books that first
appeared in print in 1910 tian richards
portrayed the title billionaire and tech
genius who wages war with a shadowy
global conspiracy he believes is
responsible for the disappearance of his
father in the books tom swift was a
white teenage inventor while on the show
he's a gay black billionaire in his
twenties but that big change did little
to grab audiences attention the ratings
were strikingly low with a negligible
0.1 rating in the coveted 18-49
demographic as reported by deadline the
show's edgy content may have been what
really led to its demise as nexstar
media group is set to acquire the cw and
reportedly isn't interested in
programming that isn't squeaky clean
debuting in february 2020 fox's
quick-witted animated family sitcom
duncanville arrived packed with talent
co-created by amy poehler and longtime
simpsons writer mike scully the show
revolved around a wildly mediocre but
self-aggrandizing teenage boy named
duncan voiced bipolar a typical episode
featured him bristling against parental
control and hanging out with his crew of
near-duel friends alas duncanville just
couldn't perform at a competitive enough
level for fox which boasts more animated
shows in production than it has space
for on its sunday night animation block
with established hits like the simpsons
bob's burgers and family guy and newer
entries like house broken and the great
north the network also had to make room
for upcoming cartoons gropopolis
produced by community creator dan harmon
and grimsberg starring jon hamm the
ratings for duncanville season 3 were so
bad averaging 530 000 viewers per
episode that fox pulled it off the
schedule and at some point we'll dump
six unaired episodes onto hulu
leaving by
why women kill is a darkly comic crime
anthology detailing the events that led
up to the titular murders debuting on
cbs all access in 2019 the first season
concerned three different time periods
where the same pasadena house and
cheating were involved season two
followed in 2021 on cbs all-access
successor paramount plus with a
standalone story about a new character
driven to commit homicide
in december 2021 paramount plus ordered
a new set of episodes of why women kill
the show reportedly placed high on a top
10 list of the streamers most popular
and visible programs the new slate of
episodes went into pre-production but
then on july 1 2022 paramount plus
reversed course and decided that it
didn't want any more y women kill after
all and cancel the series after just two
seasons
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one